eux aussi pardon était dans la rue ce
sont les salariés de la culture artistes
techniciens compagnie ils réclament un
plan de relance du secteur avant la
reprise des spectacles le 15 décembre à
tours place anatole france ils étaient
quelques centaines pour dénoncer leur
agonie
audrey champigny
[Musique]
danseurs musiciens comédiens techniciens
c'est toute la grande famille de la
culture qui étaient dans la rue c'est
mulhouse au son de la fanfare ou du dj
arborons la croix-blanche des
intermittents des artistes manifestant
pacifiquement leur colère et leur
désarroi face à une situation
catastrophique
moi j'avais cette date en décembre elles
ont été annulées la semaine passée il va
falloir que ça réouvre pour nous dans
des situations dans des mesures
sanitaires à respecter bien évidemment
mais il va falloir que ça bouge et que
ça recommence pas ce qu'on peut
s'entasser dans des trains on peut
s'entasser dans des avions peu sentais
assez dense 10 paires marché mais on
peut pas être se faire du bien à la tête
aussi parce que les gens commencent à
être un peu mal malgré une année blanche
et un statut gelé quand sera-t-il l'an
prochain dans les rangs beaucoup de
jeunes mais pas seulement inquiets pour
leur avenir
bah c'est très compliqué on a
l'intelligence mais on travaille pas que
c'est bon c'est très compliqué on aura
sûrement du mal à renouveler notre à sa
religion
là on est surtout en soutien parce qu'en
fait on est une
les parents d'une artiste metteur en
scène auteur et on s'aperçoit que depuis
pratiquement six suis moins c'est une
grosse grosse galère parce qu'en fait il
ya eu le premier confinement pas de date
donc pas de rénumération ensuite il ya
eu un laps de temps ils ont pu faire
quelques dates et là on retombe dans un
dans un travers c'est incroyable dès le
15 décembre aussi la situation
épidémique le permet musées et théâtres
ou encore cinéma et concerts pourront
reprendre tout doucement